just outside Washington in Lorton
Virginia is a prosperous little corner
of America this is home to Alice Butler
short the brains behind Virginia women
for Trump her mission persuading women
across this battleground state to
overlook Trump's faults and embrace him
too if he's a little crude sometimes
frankly we don't care we don't care we
wanted we wanted to fix things we wanted
to fix it it's more important that he
fixed this country than it is that every
word out of his mouth is politically
correct we've had it with that we've had
it Alice has seen the world born in
Ireland she's lived in faraway places
from Hong Kong and Singapore to Somalia
her home and garden of full of echoes of
that cosmopolitan life but Alice's every
inch an American with a traditional view
of the kind of leadership America needs
Virginia women like strong men strong
man with a compassionate heart that's
what we have in Donald J Trump we have a
strong brilliant leader with a
compassionate heart today's a special
day listen her friends are heading out
to host a tea party it's a moment to get
the grassroots motivated for the final
months of the campaign everyone is
dressed to the nines and ready to have a
good time as the guests stream in for
all the smiles all is not well in the
Trump campaign after another string of
controversies Trump is sinking in the
polls including here in Virginia so when
it's time to rally the crowd Alice
witch's hat
we know he's not a racist and we know
he's not bad to women are all the other
things the liberal media is trying to
label him with the country is we
bankrupt we're being invaded by illegals
and Trump is the only guy who seems to
understand what the people watch after
the speeches are over and the tea and
cakes are polished off we ask people why
they think women should vote for Trump
and against Hillary Clinton I want to be
safe I want my granddaughter's to be
safe so um I just wish people would just
give him a chance let him show you know
what he's got hand Second Amendment you
ain't taking it you're not taking my
guns what really strikes me with Hilary
is the fact that she lies she has lied
to Congress she has lied to our country
I cannot vote for a liar because I have
to answer to my children I think that
Donald Trump tends to get full of
himself once in a while I don't think
he's got a problem with women I think a
lot of that is just blown out of
proportion and I think a lot of that is
just the other side yak yak yak and
wherever that yak yak yak comes from
Alice knows that it's not going to stop
she's getting ready for a hard battle
ahead it's going to get worse it's gonna
get a lot worse just keep going stay
positive we know who he is we know what
he's all about we know what he can do
for the fruit of their country and don't
give up you know when the going gets
tough the tough get going and Virginia
women for Trump are tough that toughness
will be put to the test in the months to
come but if these women succeed their
next tea party could be at the White
House